Louie waterson here at attic question,
how would you suggest someone who's a jack of all trades and master of none
conduct themselves while you're probably high in openness,
high in creativity.
And one of the dangers of being high creativity,
especially if you're also high in neuroticism,
is that it's hard for creative people to catalyze and identity because they're
basically pan like,
you know,
like Peter Pan or like,
or like Pan,
which means everything that God of the forest is the god of everything to some
degree.
And the problem with being everything is that you're also nothing at the same
time because you'd never specialize.
And so I would say that if you're,
I think that being a jack of all trades is pretty damn useful.
But I would also say that it's really necessary to buckle down and find one
primary mode of discipline and Jack or Louie,
if you can't figure out what you should do,
then guess just pick something that you think that you could hit hard and
concentrate on.
You don't have to be perfect at it.
You don't even have to get it right,
but pick something rather than nothing or pick something rather than all things.
And then set yourself to master that because you know,
you need to have a,
a,
um,
a discipline,
a primary discipline.
It's absolutely necessary to succeed in life.
Now,
once you have a primary discipline,
then you can branch out and,
and become a multiplicity in your disciplined approach and then you're
absolutely bloody unstoppable.
But you really need that initial disciplinary routine.
You know,
this is something neat you knew up,
knew very well.
Um,
he said,
for example,
I just wrote about this today,
that um,
it was the long unfreedom of the,
of Europe's subjugation to the dogmatic structures of the Catholic Church that
ennobled the European mind and gave it the capacity to widely range that it
eventually developed,
but it was that initial subjugation,
not initial voluntary slavery that produced the discipline that produced the
spirit that can then go out and do other things.
And it's really,
really useful to subjugate yourself something to something voluntarily.
You know,
I think that's partly why it's useful to practice a religious faith because you
subject yourself to a disciplinary structure that way.
And you might think,
well that's all oppressed if in all of that.
And of course that's true,
but it also makes you disciplined.
And once you're disciplined,
like you're,
you're like a sharpened sword man,
like a well tempered blade.
And then you can go out there and operate in the world.
So,
and if you haven't found your passion,
then I would say,
well,
don't wait around until you find the damn thing because you may never find it is
pick something and focus on it.
You know?
And if you move strongly and forthrightly towards it for a number of months at
least,
or even a number of years,
and then you find,
well that wasn't the thing for you,
it isn't going to be a waste to anyways.
Because most of the time the pursuit of any discipline,
knowledge pays off,
even if it doesn't pay off in the way that you initially expect.